I'm happy okay
yeah you dedicated to quality
ingredients means that there will be
more of a demand for quality ingredients
whether it's our food or our cleaning
products we want to make sure that they
align with the strong values sprouts is
empowering kids to empower their
families through healthy choices there's
really no recipe that we do that comes
out perfect but the process of doing it
is what's the perfect yeah go around and
get it all better kids are just like
blank canvases and you can impress on
them and influence them you guys know
how much sugar you're supposed to have
in a day or pieces you can see like who
they are really in how they cook you
guys want to roll those into little
rectangles like this okay yeah now we're
going to get messy with the flour every
time the class bars and all the kids
walk in they pick up the knives that
immediately departs to recharge my soul
kind of reminds me of myself as a young
cook this one uses special about sprouts
getting super hands-on instead of just
observing
we made Kylie a Tele from scratch and
bolognese sauce it's just full when they
all pick up sharp knives but I love it
oh I want to do that I was informed
early on that would have this young kid
man Alex he had pretty impeccable knife
skills I was over helping the kids with
the pasta machine then he's like over
the pot cooking pasta music shaft shaft
like he already considers himself like a
cook
keep that up if you drop that right in
there
spend a lot of my childhood in the
garden with my father and another half
of that time was in the kitchen with my
mom so I guess that all kind of came
around full circle
okay cutie my dad he would talk about
the whole process the circle of life and
food and everything plays into that
including what we used to clean our
surfaces in our dishes in our walls and
our stove top priorities feeding for the
fed having healthier kitchen will create
healthier bodies and then those habits
will be in place being sustainable as a
part of the process and so having
products dedicated to being non-toxic is
important you want to be in our kitchen
just as clean as we made it when we
started ok that's how we want to raise
our kids to be safe and healthy and
clean and happy and colorful time to eat
education is at our fingertips but if
you don't have the experience to make it
fun so I can be open to it
we're not just a cookie school we call
them sprouting chef there's starting to
bloom into these kids who make decisions
about their food and their recipes and
how they're going to share it with their
family so it has to be fun or else it's
not going to sit with them it's not
going to plant in them
[Music]